when used correctly push notifications
can be an extremely powerful way to
drive user engagement but when used
incorrectly they can do the exact
opposite and drive users to uninstall
your app luckily there's a service
called firebase cloud messaging that
allows you to be smart about the way you
broadcast notifications to your users
take it from me be smart be safe in
today's video you'll learn how to
receive messages from a front-end
flutter app and also how to broadcast
them from a back-end cloud function
we'll look at how to broadcast
notifications to a single device or user
to a topic or to a segment of your user
base based on the analytics data that
you collect by the end of this video
you'll be able to combine these
techniques together to create a
sophisticated pipeline for app
notifications if you're new here like
and subscribe and you can find the full
source code on fire ship IO and congrats
to mateo Petrovich your last week's
t-shirt winner but there will be another
giveaway with this video all you have to
do is leave a comment below now before
we get into the actual source code let's
talk about the three main ways that you
can send push notifications with
firebase Cloud messaging the most broad
approach is to send a notification to a
segment of your users this could be as
broad as all the users for your Android
app but typically you're going to drill
down to a smaller audience for example
you might want to target all of your
Korean Android users whose last app
engagement was more than ten days ago
and that will tell you exactly how many
users will receive this notification as
well as their relative size to the total
user base on top of that you can use
firebase predictions to dynamically
segment your users and send
notifications based on the type of
engagement you're trying to get and that
means you can just fire the UX person
who's in charge of doing this manually
and like google's AI handle it what are
you getting fire me
no I already why are you still here
another option is to manually subscribe
a user to a notification topic this is
useful if you want a user to opt into a
certain topic or if you want to
programmatically assign them to a topic
in the background of your app for
example a user might follow a certain
category like puppies so you want to
subscribe them to puppy notifications in
the third and most personalized way to
send notifications is to send them to a
single device or user and you can do
that because every device that you have
permission to send notifications to will
give you a token a token itself is just
a string that identifies the device and
in a few minutes we'll look at how we
can save these tokens to
firestore and associate them with a user
and that makes it possible to send
notifications based on individual user
activities
now as we'll see in this video the
actual sending of notifications can
either be done on the firebase console
or you can do it programmatically with a
cloud function in most real-world
applications you'll be doing most of the
notification sending with a cloud
function especially if you're sending to
individual device tokens now that you
know a little bit about firebase cloud
messaging
let's go ahead and jump into a flutter
app that has already been configured
with firebase for both iOS and Android
on Android there's only one additional
optional step to setup push
notifications you just need to add this
intent filter to your Android manifest
file on iOS there are a few more steps
involved because you need to register a
certificate with the Apple push
notification service there's already a
detailed official guide for this so I'll
go ahead and link to that in the video
description the next thing we'll take a
look at is the pub spec Yamma file and
you can see here we have firebase core
auth cloud fire store and messaging now
if we go into the main dart file you'll
see here that I'm importing dart io so
we can do platform checking and we'll
also import our firebase services now
typically I try to keep the business
logic separated from the UI logic but
this is a situation where our logic is
pretty tightly coupled together and I
think it makes the most sense to handle
everything in a single stateful widget
so this message handler widget will take
care of getting permission from the user
saving the device token to the database
if necessary and displaying the actual
UI elements when a notification is
received now the first thing that we
want to focus on is the UI and there are
three different callbacks that you need
to know about the on message callback
will typically be called when the app is
running in the foreground that means the
user is actively using the app when the
message is received then you have the
onresume callback which will be called
when the app is running in the
background and the user clicks on the
notification from the actual device and
the third callback on launch will run if
the user clicks on the notification but
the app is completely terminated and
needs to reboot now when it comes to
Android you need to set the click action
to flutter notification click to use the
background or terminated callbacks and
we'll look at exactly how to do that
when we get to the cloud functions now
the only callback that we care to
implement for this demo is on message
when the app is in the foreground and we
can use one of flutters built-in widgets
like a snack bar or an alert dialog the
snack bar approach is a lot more subtle
because it just
they bar down at the bottom and will be
automatically dismissed if the user
doesn't engage with it but if you have a
really important message that should
interrupt the current experience then
you can use an alert dialog and that
will force the user to manually dismiss
the message inside of an it state will
call FCM configure to set up the
callbacks that will handle the message
when it's received by the device and
each one of these callbacks will give us
access to the actual notification data
payload to display a snack bar we can
first define the snack bar widget and
then we'll set the text to the
notification title and you can
optionally add an action here to go to a
different screen when the user presses
on the notification then to actually
show it we call scaffold of context show
snack bar which will look up the widget
tree for the nearest scaffold and
display it so that's all we need for a
snack bar if we want to show an alert
dialog we can use the built in show
dialog method and then define a builder
that defines an alert dialog and we can
pass that the notification title and the
body and then we can dismiss the alert
by simply calling navigator pop now we
can also define the on launch and on
resume callbacks or we can leave them
blank which will just cause the app to
be opened if a notification is clicked
on in most cases you'll probably want to
navigate to a specific screen when the
user clicks on a notification in the
background at this point we actually
have everything in place we need to
start receiving notifications on the
device as long as that device is Android
on iOS you need to explicitly request
permission from the user and that's
actually really easy to do we simply
call FCM request notification permission
and then pass in the iOS notification
settings now if we go to the firebase
console and send a notification to a
segment it should be received by this
device now the next thing we might want
to do is subscribe the user to a
specific topic you can subscribe or
unsubscribe from a topic with a single
line of code you might do this entirely
in the background or you might have a
button that says subscribe to puppy
notifications that the user clicks and
now they're subscribed to that topic of
notifications and now if we want to send
a notification to all devices subscribe
to that topic we can do so in the
firebase console or with a cloud
function but what if we want to send
notifications to an individual user or
device to make that happen we'll need to
retrieve the fcm token from this device
and then save it in a back-end database
somewhere like firestore before we
implement the code let's start by
looking at the actual database model we
have a user's collection that contains
some information about a user profile
and
under that we have a sub collection
called tokens and each document in this
collection represents a device token
that the user has given us permission to
send notifications to and a token is
nothing more than a unique string so we
can use the actual device token as the
document ID in the sub collection and
that just makes it easy to enforce
uniqueness for each document in this
collection now getting back to our
flutter code the next thing we'll do is
implement a method called save device
token and I'm just referencing a mock
user ID but in a real app you would most
likely await the auth current user after
you've already logged a user into your
app from there we can retrieve the FCM
token from the device by calling get
token and then we'll make a reference to
that token subcollection under the user
that uses the FCM token itself as the
document ID and then we can also save
some optional information here if we
want like a created at time stamp or the
platform operating system from there
we'll go back to our an it state
lifecycle hook on this widget and on
Android we can simply run this code when
the widget is initialized because the
token should already be available but on
iOS we need to make sure that the user
has actually finished giving us
permission so we'll go ahead and listen
to the stream and then once we have data
then we'll go ahead and save the device
token now go ahead and restart your
flutter app and you should see the
device token being saved a firestore
when you fire it up and you can go ahead
and copy that token and bring it over to
the FCM screen and you can send a
notification directly to this device so
that takes care of all of our front-end
code but now the question becomes how do
we dynamically send notifications to a
user based on their actual activity in
this app and the best answer to that
question is firebase cloud functions
although you can use any of the firebase
tab and SDKs to send messages go ahead
and run firebase and it functions from
the root of your project and I would
highly recommend using typescript as the
language here and if you're not an
expert with typescript or JavaScript
don't worry because the implementation
details for this code are really simple
first we'll go into the index TS file
and import firebase admin initialize it
and then setup variables for fire store
and FCM when it comes to sending
notifications to a specific topic you'll
most likely do that when something
changes in the database for example you
might have a puppy's collection and you
want to notify everybody subscribe to
the puppies topic when a new document is
added to the database we can do that by
setting up a cloud function that listens
to the fire
on create event in the puppies
collection when a new document is
created that's going to give us access
to the puppy data on that document and
then we can create a notification
payload with that data the cool thing
about this is that we can use the data
in the firestore document to customize
the notification itself for example
we'll say puppy name is ready for
adoption now there's a lot of different
ways you can customize the notification
itself but the most important properties
are the title body and icon because they
dictate how it appears on the actual
notification tray on the device and
you'll also want to set the click action
to flutter notification click if you
want to use those background callbacks
that we looked at earlier and the final
step is to simply send a notification
which we can do by calling FCM send a
topic along with the topic name and the
notification payload and that's all the
code it takes to broadcast a
notification out to potentially millions
of devices that are subscribed to this
puppy's topic now let's go ahead and
write a second cloud function that will
listen to the orders collection and then
it will send out a notification to an
individual user whenever they've
received a new order when an order
document is created we'll assume that
there is a price a product and then a
user ID for whatever user sold that
product in the cloud function we'll go
ahead and take that user ID to make a
query to that tokens collection under
the user ID that will give us a query
that returns all the device tokens for a
specific user now because each one of
those documents uses the actual FCM
token as its ID we can simply map the
snapshots down to an array of the
document IDs then we'll go ahead and
format the message payload just like we
did in a previous example and then we'll
say FCM send to device with this array
of tokens and that will send out a push
notification to every device owned by
this user now the final step is to
deploy the functions then if we go into
fire store and create a document it
should broadcast the notification to our
emulator or local device and we now have
a full stack solution for a cloud
messaging that can handle multiple
paradigms of app notifications I'm gonna
go ahead and wrap things up there if
this video helped you please like and
subscribe and consider becoming a pro
member at fire ship IO to get access to
the full footer firebase force thanks
for watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]